vamos a repasar un poco el valor
absoluto antes de meternos en las
ecuaciones con el valor absoluto porque
cuando yo hablaba del valor absoluto
realmente lo que estaba pensando eran
una distancia por ejemplo si me tomo el
valor absoluto de menos 1 me estoy
fijando qué tan lejos está el menos 1
del 0 si nosotros tomamos aquí una recta
numérica y déjame dibujar una mejor
recta numérica no me gusta más esta y
aquí está el 0 el menos 1 si te das
cuenta está a una unidad de distancia
del 0 por lo tanto el valor absoluto de
menos 1 es 1 y de igual manera si yo me
tomo el valor absoluto de 1 te das
cuenta que la distancia del 1 al 0 1 por
lo tanto también el valor absoluto de 1
es uno y bueno esta es una forma de
pensarlo como la distancia que tiene un
número al cero pero también hay otra
forma de pensarlo por ejemplo si me tomo
el valor absoluto de menos 7.346 esto
siempre me lo manda positivo los números
negativos me lo mandan a su versión en
positivo mientras que los números
positivos se quedan en su versión en
positivo y bueno esto nos da pie a
pensar en ecuaciones con valor absoluto
si nosotros tenemos por ejemplo x 5 el
valor absoluto de x menos 5 igual a 10 y
quiero resolver esta ecuación como la
resuelvo bueno pues una forma de
pensarlo es qué números están a una
distancia de 10 unidades del 5 o tal vez
otra forma de pensando es que números si
le tomas el valor absoluto nos da 10 ya
esos números hay que igualar los a x
menos encuestas una forma sistemática de
verlo y de hecho es la mejor forma de
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones así que
voy a poner primero x menos 5 es igual a
10 porque date cuenta que el valor
absoluto de 1010 si x menos 5 vale 10
entonces me voy a tomar el valor
absoluto de 10 pero el valor absoluto de
10 es 10
entonces se cumpliría esta ecuación pero
también existe otro también puedes tomar
como x menos 5 igual a menos 10 si esta
parte de aquí adentro es menos 10 y le
tomas el valor absoluto al menos 10 pues
el valor absoluto de menos 10 también es
10 recuerda que no manda a su versión en
positivo por lo tanto ya tenemos aquí
dos ecuaciones y por lo tanto dos
posibles resultados o x menos 5 es igual
a 10
yo puedo sumar 5 de la ecuación me queda
que este es igual a 15 en su dado caso x
5 es igual a menos 10 y si somos 5 damos
la ecuación me queda que x es igual a
menos 5 ambos valores de x que acabo de
encontrar x igual aquí el xiv y xv al
menos 5 son ambos la respuesta de esta
ecuación con valor absoluto 15 menos 5
es 10 y el valor absoluto de 10 es 10 y
menos 55 en 10 y el valor absoluto al
menos 10 es 10 por lo tanto ambos
cumplen y ambos son mis soluciones de
esta ecuación con valor absoluto y se me
antoja ser otro ejemplo así que vamos a
bajarnos para acá así que vamos a
tomarnos otra ecuación y se me ocurre
poner x + 2 esto igual a 6 esta tampoco
está tan difícil sin embargo es lo que
quiero que veas es el mismo concepto o x
+ 2 es igual a 6 positivo porque si el
valor absoluto de 666 entonces x + 2
podría ser 6 o en su dado caso tenemos
una segunda solución si x + 2 es igual a
menos 6 porque recuerda que él
en absoluto de menos 6 también 6 por lo
tanto x + 2 o puede ser 6 o puede ser
menos 6 en el primer caso si resto todos
tenemos la ecuación me queda que x es
igual a 4 mientras que en el segundo
caso x es igual a menos 8 si paso el 2
del otro lado con signo contrario o x es
igual a 4 o x es igual a menos 8 y así
de fácil y así de sencillo podemos
resolver esta ecuación con valdrá
austronautas vamos a ver que sí es
cierto porque también lo podríamos ver
como una distancia podrías pensar que
esto es lo mismo que x menos menos 2
igual a 6 y pensar cuáles son los
números que están a una distancia de 6
del -2 fíjate bien aquí arriba teníamos
por ejemplo cuáles son los números que
están a distancias de 10 del 5 aquí es
lo mismo cuáles son los números que
están a una distancia de 6 del -2 y
bueno pues la respuesta es 4 y menos 84
está una distancia de 6 del -2 y menos 8
también puedes hacer una recta numérica
para comprobarlo por ti mismo pero bueno
ya que me están gustando mucho los
ejemplos vamos a hacer otro ejemplo me
voy a tomar un ejemplo un poco más
difícil pero te vas a ver
un poco es nada del otro mundo me voy a
tomar el valor absoluto de 4 x 1 esto
igual a 19 y si te das cuenta realmente
tampoco hay tanta ciencia en esto lo
único que hice es poner una ecuación un
poco más difícil de resolver pero bueno
aquí está diciendo que 4x menos 1 puede
ser en su dado caso 19 o también 4 x
menos 1 recuerda que tenemos una segunda
solución 4x menos 1 puede ser también
igual a menos 19 4 x menos 1 es igual a
menos 19 y bueno si de la primera
ecuación despejamos a x primero vamos a
pasar el 1 de ambos lados de la ecuación
y lo vamos a pasar sumando entonces me
queda que 4x es igual a 20 también voy a
hacer lo mismo este lado de la ecuación
no va a quedar que 4x es igual a menos
19 más 1 que es menos 18 y después voy a
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre
4 me queda que x es igual a 5 en este
caso mientras que en el otro si dividido
ambos lados entre cuatro me queda que x
es igual a menos 18 entre 4 o en su dado
caso menos nueve medio
- 9 medios y ya están aquí tengo la
solución de esta ecuación que tiene el
valor absoluto o x igual a 5 o x igual a
menos nueve medios resuelven esta
ecuación con valor absoluto
ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación
con valor absoluto 4 x 5 20 menos 119 y
después 4 x menos 9 medios me da menos
18 menos 12 menos 19 y cuando toma el
valor absoluto también me da 19 por lo
tanto y aquí tengo mis dos soluciones y
ahora vamos a ver otra cosa un poco
distinta vamos a pensar ahora en una
función que tengan que ver con valor
absoluto lo voy a tomar la función y es
igual al valor absoluto de x más 3 como
se ve la gráfica de esta función sin
embargo lo primero que quiero que
pienses de esta función es en dos casos
el primer caso puede ser que x + 3 sea
positivo y cuando tomamos el valor
absoluto de algo positivo se queda igual
entonces me queda x 3 es mayor que 0 es
algo positivo y también tenemos otro
caso que x más 3 sea menor que cero es
decir toma el valor absoluto de un
número negativo si x + 3 es mayor que 0
la función que da tal cual porque
recuerda que el valor absoluto de algo
positivo es el mismo por lo tanto me
quedaría allí es igual a x + 3 y date
cuenta que se queda igual porque cuando
yo tengo un número positivo él le tomo
el valor absoluto se queda el mismo
número y bueno si de aquí despejó a x en
esta desigualdad voy a obtener que x es
mayor que menos 3 si resto de ambos
lados de la ecuación o más bien de ambos
lados de la desigualdad 3 y me queda que
x es mayor que menos 3 bueno este es mi
primer caso cuando x 3 es mayor que 0
ahora también tengo otro caso que x más
3 sea menor que cero si x más 3 es menor
que cero date cuenta que esto que está
aquí adentro va a ser negativo y
entonces cuando me toma el valor
absoluto de algo negativo lo convierte
en positivo y eso en matemáticas quiere
decir que lo voy a multiplicar por menos
es decir que ye me va a quedar igual a
menos x + 3 y conoce eso pues porque
fíjate en esto si yo me tomo el valor
absoluto de algo negativo pues la
función valor absoluto lo que hace es
mandar me la a positivo con el mismo
valor entonces cómo convierto algo
positivo pues multiplicando por menos
por ejemplo el mayor absoluto de menos
55 lo único que hice fue multiplicar al
menos 5 x menos para que me diera 5
positivo es justo por eso que me queda
aquí es igual a menos x más 3 en
paréntesis y bueno si de aquí despejó a
x me queda que esta función es cierta
cuando x es menor que menos 3 es decir
que estoy separando esta función en dos
partes cuando x + 3 es menor que cero
cuando lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto es menor que cero y cuando lo
que está dentro de lo absoluto es mayor
que cero así que vamos a ver cómo se ve
la gráfica de esto déjame dibujar dos
ejes este es mi eje de las x y está
emerge de las 10 y bueno lo primero que
voy a hacer es fijarme en la primera
ecuación en la ecuación demorado y tengo
que es igual a menos x más 3 esto es
exactamente lo mismo y voy a distribuir
en menos que menos x menos 3 y por lo
tanto darte cuenta que la gráfica de
esto es una línea recta la cual tiene
como ordenado origen al menos tres es
decir corta en el eje de la siesta menos
3 vamos a ponerlo aquí menos 1 - 2 - 3
pasa por este punto
si despejamos a x vamos a ver que corta
el eje de las x también en unos 3 porque
cuando hay es igual a 0
me queda que 0 es igual a menos x menos
3 y sitech y despejó x me queda que x
vale menos 3 por lo tanto también
intersecta al eje de las x en el valor
de menos 3 y como es una recta pues
entonces ya tengo dos puntos y ya puedo
dibujar esta recta es algo así déjame
tomar estos valores y déjame tratar de
trazar esta recta lo mejor posible tanto
para aquí como para acá bueno esto es si
x + 3 es menor que cero pero ahora vamos
a fijarnos qué es lo que pasa con
segunda información yo sé que la gráfica
se ve como y es igual a x + 3 por cierto
intersecta el eje de las 10 en el valor
de 3 positivo si quiero encontrar otro
punto cuando llévale 0 x vale menos 3 es
decir que también pasa por este punto y
ya puedo dibujar de aquí mi recta mi
segunda recta de mi segunda información
que me dan se ve como esta recta de
amarillo ya tengo mis dos rectas de las
informaciones que me dan ahora vamos a
fijarnos en algo con mucho
dice se cumple la ecuación demorado
cuando x es menor que menos 3 es decir
todos los valores de x que sean menores
que menos 3 pues son todos estos que
están aquí es justo lo que estoy
poniendo mientras que por otra parte en
mi segunda información me dice que x es
mayor que menos 3 es decir que funciona
esta recta cuando x es mayor que menos 3
y por lo tanto es esto otro de rojo que
estoy poniendo aquí y ya está ya con
esto tenemos la gráfica de esta función
de un valor absoluto es esto de rne que
me quedo esta vez cuando x es menor que
menos 3 se comporta como la gráfica que
tenemos de morado mientras cuando x es
mayor que menos 3 se comporta como una
gráfica de amarillo y nos queda esta v
de color rojo esta es nuestra gráfica
que representa a la función con valor
absoluto con la que empezamos